le phare de bel air
en dépit de la dangerosité des côtes
seuls deux phares sont construits sur le
littoral réunionnais celui de sainte
suzanne en 1846 et quarante ans plus
tard celui de la pointe des galets
aujourd'hui disparu
le relevé des fonds marins réalisé dans
les années 1840 met en évidence deux
rochers à fleur d'eau face à la pointe
de bel air pour prévenir le danger
menaçant les bateaux on décide d'y
installer un phare
une tour de 20 mètres de haut le
surplombe de style toscan elle rappelle
les colonnes néoclassique du muséum
d'histoire naturelle de saint denis
l'escalier en bois a été entièrement
refait en métal au début des années 2000
73 marches conduisent jusqu'au système
d'éclairage une lentille de fresnel dont
le feu est visible 18 milles nautiques
soit plus de 30 km
m
entretenu pendant plus de cent quarante
ans par un gardien il est automatisée
depuis 1996
d'une superficie totale de 3400 mètres
carrés le phare comprend à sa base un
vaste bâtiment rectangulaire
après avoir abrité pendant plus d'un
siècle bureau salle des machines et
logement du gardien il accueille
aujourd'hui une salle d'exposition
bel air est l'un des trente quatre
phares français classé monument
historique entre 2010 et 2012